a 19th century mausoleum in Lucknow a
refuge for gay men like Arif Jafar and
his partner of over 10 years it's a
place they can be free from society's
gays in a country where a law
criminalizing homosexuality known as
section 377 is routinely used as a cover
to hound gay people it is making their
lives hell they are they face everyday
face blackmails extortion rape
harassment beating up 40 percent of them
just commit society just because of fear
that they would be outed by the police
or the by the community because it is
still seen as a criminal thing Arif
knows that only too well he runs HIV
awareness programs among the working
class gay population an activity fraught
with risk in India several years ago he
and his colleagues were thrown into
prison they were charged with conspiracy
to commit sodomy and possess so-called
obscene materials it was a shock because
the what we were trying was trying to
say lies and we they are being
imprisoned and that was horrific
because in jailed for initial ten days
we were denied drinking water we were
being beaten up regularly and that left
so many scars Arif lost most of his
teeth because of the beatings and the
poor hygiene in prison he was shunned by
his friends it took years before he
dared to enter a police station again
but he hasn't given up the fight he's
now one of the petitioners
pushing India's top court to
decriminalize homosexuality among the
gay community the poor are the most
vulnerable in barrio along with no one
at this workshop on safe sex
there was lots of pressure on me to get
married as a man your
expected to do that and run the family
no one in my family or my neighborhood
knows I'm gay they did they'd call me a
fact my family wouldn't accept me
anymore anyway RF spends long hours at
the office
he draws strength from his faith and his
family especially his mother who has
been hugely supportive in the evening
artifice work is far from over he goes
to public parks my homosexual men can
find sexual partners and yet remain
anonymous in the shadows the risk of
contracting HIV is high and that's not
the only danger these men when they are
approaching their customers
police-constable thread them of putting
them into jail on the under the
protection of section 377 lat
and and use that protects to blackmail
them extort money or rape them and that
is why we feel that the law should go
because it it violates our basic
fundamental rights to exist human risk
on India's Supreme Court was expected to
deliver a verdict on whether the law is
constitutional there's a surge of hope
in the gay community that they may
finally be able to step out of the
shadows